you're telling everybody to wear a mask
whether they've had an infection or a
vaccine if we're not spreading the
infection
isn't it just theater no it's not the
vaccine and you're wearing two masks
isn't that theater
no that's not here we go again with the
theater what proof is there that there
are significant reinfections with
hospitalizations and death
from the variants none in our country
zero
all right so that was a senate committee
hearing and senator rand paul
joins us this morning to talk about what
exactly went down what happened
good morning to you good morning thanks
for having me you're welcome so senator
tell us
you know set that up for the audience at
home what happened
we've had 90 million vaccines in our
country about 40 to 50 million people
have been vaccinated
we've got another 30 million people have
gotten the disease naturally like i have
and the question is do they have
immunity but we've always believed that
that's the science of vaccines is that
when you get an infection or you get the
vaccination you develop immunity
and yet he's keeps moving the goal posts
and saying
well you might get this variant from
south africa
and my point to him is show us the
evidence show us the scientific evidence
that people who have already had kovid
or people who have already had the
vaccine
are getting it again if they're getting
it in large numbers and they're getting
ill and going to the hospital and dying
we should know that
but it's not true it's his conjecture he
says we
might get it therefore we need to wear
the mask for another year
yeah this is equivalent of saying well
we might get the spanish flu
so maybe we should wear the mask until
the spanish flu comes back
it's a ridiculous notion not based on
science
and what he is doing is theater and it
goes against the science of vaccines dr
fauci has immunity he can't get it again
but he's wearing a mask because it's one
of his
noble lies to convince everybody to wear
masks
but it's not true if you've been
vaccinated you don't need to wear a mask
so that's that's really your message is
once you're
once you're vaccinated uh you don't need
to wear a mask
around other people have also been
vaccinated which is a great sales pitch
for everybody getting the shot
right exactly i'm not against the
vaccine i'm for people backs
being vaccinated in fact that's how
we're getting out of this both natural
immunity
having had the infection plus those
being vaccinated is good
once you are vaccinated and you're two
weeks out from the second dose
you are safe and there is no record so
far
of anybody being hospitalized or dying
that's been vaccinated
there's also no record of people who've
gotten it naturally
being reinfected and being hospitalized
or dying
so what we have is that it's very very
safe once you've had the vaccine very
very safe once you've had the infection
and we should be getting that reward in
fact it should be the incentive for
people to go out and get vaccinated is
that you want to wear your
but dr fauci gets this upside down he's
such a government
worrywart that he says well you might
get else someday
well we might get anything we might get
the spanish blue again
but that's not the way science works he
needs to show us evidence
as to why it's incumbent upon him to
prove to us that we need to wear a mask
not the other way around that's a great
point senator by what standard
on this same point by what standard do
you believe dr fauci or others
as you put it government worry warts
would effectively say
take the mask off what what is that
threshold
other than what he's already said that's
great
because i think it leads to the answer
being never because there's ultimately
always something that could be around
the corner
see he's saying the south african
variant might come
i'm saying to him show me that the south
africa
south african variant is infecting
people
causing them to go to the hospital and
causing them to die in significant
numbers
if it's a significant pathogen i'll
listen
but the thing is is most the thing we're
finding out is the opposite that the
vaccine actually worked on all the
variants so far
and that there isn't massive death and
re-hospitalization
from people who have been vaccinated
this is good news instead of saying it
might happen
he needs to show me a study a scientific
study showing that it is happening
because i'm not willing to wear a mask
for the rest of my life for something
that might happen
unless you show me that it actually is
happening so the science
the proof should and the burden of proof
should be on there they shouldn't just
get to say
oh wear a mask as dr fauci likes wearing
a mask and the whole double mask is
complete theater there's no science
saying that he can get reinfected there
are no studies showing reinfection after
vaccine but
but just to be clear you're you're
talking you know he was talking about
after the vaccine for people who have
not had the vaccine
and have not had covet and don't have
the uh immunities in their system
those people should wear a mask when
they cannot social distance
i think it depends on their risk factors
if they're a kid the risk factor of
getting this and dying from this is
virtually
zero and so i'm not a big fan of having
kids wear masks
i think it's teaches own if you want to
send your kid to a school that they say
wear a mask do it
you want to send your kid to a private
school they don't wear a mask i think
that's also
fine i think the risk factors are things
that individuals in a free society
should decide for themselves
if you look at all the mask mandates
throughout the country when we
instituted mass
mandates the incidence of the disease
went up particularly in december and
january as we went up exponentially
as the rise in infections occurred
everybody was wearing mass so there's
not a great deal of evidence that mass
mandates or economic lockdowns have
changed the trajectory
the only thing that's changing the
trajectory is the vaccine
so that's why i don't think people
should be tricked into thinking the mask
is the answer
the vaccine actually is the answer but
the mask really isn't an answer we've
had
rampant infection with everybody wearing
masks most people getting the infection
say they've been wearing the mask
the cloth masks don't really work at all
and so the
five masks have been shown to work in
hospital settings but none of the masks
have really been proven to work in
what what how do you think this is going
to play out let's say in a few more
months because right now no one's
hugging people are socially distanced
you're wearing the mask
people are staying in their own space
you think we'll remain like that as a
country or we go back to the way it was
ultimately the government bureaucrats
like voucher will lose people are
already pushing back i mean look
president biden's saying on july 4th you
can get together with three people
people are already doing what they want
it's a free country and they're getting
tired of these people look i meet people
all the time in their 70s that have been
vaccinated
there's a twinkle back in their eye
they're going to restaurant
bring their map they they really don't
care what president biden or fouch or
any of these so-called people are saying
they feel safe after the vaccine and i
think they should that's what the
science
and if the science says you're safe
after the vaccine what a terrible
selling message if that's true
they can go ahead and try to say that
but they're trying to tell you the
vaccine is safe and working and yet you
still can wear a mask that's a
contradictory proposition
senator while we got you here uh
yesterday the house
passed two immigration bills they
essentially passed the same things two
years ago
now they head to the senate is there any
way
they get 10 republican senators to say
you know what the democrats have great
got a great idea
on how to provide uh permanent
citizenship
for these dreamers and also farm workers
you know if they wanted an immigration
that actually talked to us
i haven't had any of them talk to me
they run the lake
and uh they won't get on the elevator
and it's ridiculous because it goes
against all the science but they still
have been vaccinated and yet they still
literally i think they fear having their
p
taken with me because they're afraid
that could be
but here's the thing with immigration
what i would say is
you have a rule at the border where we
send those back
legally they remain in mexico you can't
have any kind of forgiveness plan on the
other side
if we give three million people that are
already here illegally what does that
tell to the other millions
marching up through central senator
senator we're having a broadband problem
we can only hear about every fourth word
thank you very much for joining senator